a standard elevator in a mid-rise
building can hold a maximum weight of
one and a half tonnes assuming an
average adult weight of 160 pounds what
is the maximum number of adults who
could safely ride the elevator so we
need to do is we have to get the maximum
weight that we that the elevator can
hold in terms of pounds and just say
okay well how many adults is that so
they gave us the maximum weight in terms
of tons so they say it is one and
one-half tons and it's always easier to
be to deal with improper fractions and
mixed numbers so let's write this as an
improper fraction so one in one half
tonnes is the same thing as well one ton
is two halves and then you add another
1/2 that's three halves so you get three
halves tons or another way to think
about it is two times one is two plus
one is three so the maximum capacity is
three has tons let's think about how
many pounds that is and to do that we
have to know that there are 2,000 pounds
per ton let me write this up here we
know that there are 2,000 pounds pounds
per ton this wasn't given in the problem
anywhere this is something I knew from
past experience it's a good thing to
know in general that a ton is 2,000
pounds so I'm going to write it right
over here now how do we convert these
three half tonnes into pounds well we're
going to multiply it by something and
the units that we're going to multiply
by we want the tons to cancel out so
we're going to want to have tons in the
denominator we want tons in the
denominator so it cancels out with this
tons up here and then we want pounds in
the numerator and that's exactly what we
wrote up here there are two thousand
pounds two thousand pounds for every one
tonne or you could just say two thousand
pounds per ton you could put the one
there but it doesn't really change the
expression now if we multiply three half
tonnes times 2,000 pounds per tonne the
what will happen is that the tonnes
cancel out that was a whole point of
multiplying it by this and we would be
left with we would be left with three
halfs three halves times 2,000
times 2,000 and the only unit left is
pounds is pounds and this is the way if
you do it this way you'll never get
confused you'll know what you're you
know that the units cancel out so you're
getting the right units but if you just
think about it in your mind it should
also make sense to if two thousand if
there are two thousand pounds per tonne
and they're about one and a half tons I
should multiply one and a half times two
thousand to get the number of pounds
that makes sense it'll give me and we
know one and a half times two thousand
is three thousand but we'll figure it
out
right here so what is three-halves times
two thousand when i just told you the
answer we can actually simplify it right
over here this is going to be three
times two thousand over two pounds we
can divide the numerator and the
denominator by 2 this will become one
thousand and this will become one so
it's three times one thousand pounds or
this is equal to three thousand pounds
so what we've done so far if we've just
figured out the maximum capacity of the
elevator it can hold one and a half
tonnes which is the exact same thing as
three thousand pounds now what we need
to figure out is three thousand pounds
is equivalent to how many average
adult's of 160 pounds or how many a
hundred sixty pound people would it take
to weigh a total of three thousand
pounds well we can just divide by 160
and if you want to make sure that the
units work out remember we want this we
want our answer to be in terms of people
and we want the pounds to cancel out so
we have a pound in the numerator here so
if we divide by pounds the pounds will
cancel out and then we have we want our
leftover to be people or maybe person
person person people same thing let me
do people the the grammar of it or doing
singular program might make it a little
confusing but I think you get the
general idea now if we were to write
this out what does it tell us one person
weighs 160 pounds so there's one people
or one person for every 160 pounds so
notice if we multiply these two
expressions the pounds will cancel out
we'll be just left with people but we're
really just dividing we're multiplying
three thousand times one over 160
it's really just taking 3,000 and
dividing by 160 which makes sense we
have a capacity of 3,000 each of our
people weighs 160 pounds divided by a
hundred 60 tells you how many people but
this way you know that the units are
working out so this is going to be equal
to this is going to be equal to 3000
over 160 people that is the maximum
capacity of the elevator in terms of
average people now what is this well we
can divide the numerator and the
denominator by 10 if we divide the
numerator and denominator by 10 this
becomes 300 over 16 if we divide 300 by
if we divide 300 by 2 this becomes 150
if we divide 16 by 2 this becomes 8 now
let's see what can we do more here well
we could divide by 2 again let me
rewrite it I don't this kit so this is
the same thing as 150 over 8 people see
150 we can divide by 2 this gives us 75
and if you take 8 divided by 2 that is 4
so we have 75 divided by 4 people let me
just do that work it out so you have 75
divided by 4 4 goes into 7 one time 1
times 4 is 4
you subtract 7 minus 4 is 3 bring down
this 5 4 goes into 35 8 times 8 times 4
is 32 subtract 5 minus 2 is 3 and then
you have the decimal we're going beyond
the we're going to the right of the ones
place we're going to the tenths place
now so we can bring down a 0 over here 4
goes into 30 7 times 7 times 4 is 28 you
subtract you get to bring down another
is 0 4 goes into 20 exactly 5 times 5
times 4 is 20 and then we are done so
this expression is exactly you know the
3000 divided by 160 or the 150 divided
by 8 or the 75 divided 4 it all turns
out to be 18 point seven five people is
the capacity of the elevator 18.75
average
60 pound people would weigh 3,000 pounds
now did they want a decimal what is the
maximum number of adults who could
safely ride the elevator well if they're
all going to be average then the maximum
number of adults since you can't have
since you can't have three-quarters of a
people of a person or 75 hundredths of a
person the maximum number is going to be
18 if you have 19 average weight adults
you're going to be too heavy and the
elevator will will fall or something